l'arrivée se fait en petite foulée une
entrée en matière énergique
parce que vous allez le constater la
science du jour sera comme qui dirait
très intense va jouer là j'ai cette fois
ci on ira à fond à chaque fois deux fois
par semaine pendant deux heures de temps
l'équipage de laguiole caracoli
s'entraîne à domicile sur le front de
mer dit robert et chaque minute on
ajoute une langueur d'accord dit m cette
distance l'avait dit m
[Musique]
ah oui et toi avec l'âge que j'irai
aussi où les jeunes célèbrent difficile
quand même je m'accroche et s'est bien
mobilisé ses traits et bande à bonnot
pas mal d'années ont fait pareil et
c'est ça le secret des dieux champlain
mise en forme cohésion d'équipé
endurance de quoi être paris
physiquement et mentalement pour une
semaine de course qui s'annonce riche en
efforts et en émotions la première place
il faut savoir la défendre là on fait
tout le conte on travaille tous les
muscles du corps en version cohésion
d'équipé important justement vous avez
parlé de cohésion très important dans
dans une yole ci a pas de cohésion on
n'avance pas ensemble et donc si on
n'avance pas ensemble on gagne pas je
n'aime pas la compétition
[Musique]
c'est difficile ça va bah ça non mais
c'est compliqué mais ça c'est un clic et
ben les exercices la pétition suis au
tout mais bon après c'est important et
pourquoi c'est important
shaw un entraînement sportif ou petits
oignons concocté par le coach joris avec
des exercices sur mesure pour une
préparation d'avant tour à la hauteur
des attentes
par exemple leurs épaules vont être très
sollicitées donc vous avez vu qu'on a
fait un jeu tout à l'heure mais on
appuie sur les mains ça a l'air anodin
comme ça mais c'est une position qu'ils
ont en permanence sur les bois dressée
par jour j moins 5 pour toute l'équipe
du affaires showfloor objectif garder
coûte que coûte le titre de champion
[Musique]